Oh accidental world 10 a month called
play a I'm interesting I manage or
something if you don't know now you know
your life it's different now the I heart
music radio the wards show of music
happen what is what is it an awards show
with a lot of words and it recently
happened for music i heart radio is the
weekly two-hour program magus ryan
seacrest host and it now turned into an
award show for music it doesn't really
matter what it is exactly people showed
up to the event it wore cool interesting
fabrics and i'm going to talk about it
let's review the iHeartRadio Music
Awards red carpet fashion rolls off the
tongue Katy Perry this is cool and
geometric and elegant and interesting
and fun and other adjectives as I like
your Hannah Hart inspiring or ado I
can't take credit for that original
comparison Hannah Hart herself
instagrams that they have matching
hairdos now here's the cool interesting
thing I saw in some headlines because
this is news this isn't a gown this is a
pantsuit
there's a seam that goes right up the
crotch she's not free tutoring under
there no way not now not never sorry I
watched that video drinking out of cups
like four times over the weekend I drank
a lot this weekend ed Sheeran
you look like Ed Sheeran you look like
you can be a comedy writer young
professor recently divorced dad skater
boy go into a job interview at like a
bank that is friends dad on so many
options really cute there she is there's
my girl Heidi Klum thank God where were
you this award season I don't know Heidi
Klum is that every awards show and I am
always so thankful she's there because I
don't know why but she she's always
there she's picking and choosing the
awards that she wants to go to she's
going to the important ones didn't show
up at the Grammys which is that the I
heart music radio Awards for radio music
I do look good I like this you look like
a single mom that just finally found a
babysitter for kids and now you and your
girlfriends are going to take test tube
shots till you puke cute Noah Cyrus okay
sure this is like a very sexy Victorian
bathing suit cover up with what could be
sushi and gross hard candy emojis all
over it lots of choices that's like a
mad lift sentence but that's exactly
what I'm seeing right now then you got
sexy space shoes member when we were
younger we had moon shoes those shoes
with a bouncing that you know very
vaguely simulated what was like to be in
zero gravity on the moon these are like
the sexier knockout versions of them
it looks pretty uncomfortable but God
bless you're doing the best you can
proud of you palsy oh okay huh what I'm
broken I broke out of you broke me good
felt never goes out of style I'm getting
very mental hospital meets poncho vibe
and that's a cute combo haven't seen
that that often it's about consent your
weight why not you ten doesn't look like
it's the most comfortable thing like
you're going to have to air out those
nipples at the end of the night yeah
Demi Lovato space girl going to a
business meeting there's like future
space Fembots about to give a PowerPoint
presentation very futuristic a
professional era tinfoil yeah McLemore I
have not seen you on a red carpet in a
very long time and look at this
denim-on-denim and I have those shoes I
actually I and my Macklemore is this a
matrix is that we find out it's not a
pill it's just folk pigskin booth okay
yeah disharmony Wow no Jay whoa yeah I
think I like everything that's happening
but just like a magic I like I just I'm
trying to soft focus so I see exactly
what's going on here
I really like the Hummer and red carpets
who they think they don't go to
matchy-matchy but they kind of
coordinate and you do understand us
they're a girl group and they take
photos on red carpets like they all said
some like crazy [ __ ] to each other in
the limo on the way over that they
definitely can't take back or unhear
that they're just gonna put on a brave
face anyway so that's good kid to me I
think this is all good but like I said I
am just seeing
fabrics and patterns you all hate
touching each other
and I can appreciate that in this photo
cute Shawn Mendes of feeling weird
feelings this is a child right John I'm
feeling weird feelings you look like
you're having a great time when you look
like your parents gave you a really cool
bone structure in your face and your
child's cool face good for you that song
about you can treat you better makes it
feel weird things and you're a child cue
to change mother I'm sorry but this
makes me laugh how can you have facial
expressions like that when you're
dressed like that I love this you guys
look like you're having a strange time
they're being very provocative I'm
seeing ankles on both of them and
scandalous the stature of you might get
flag provocative
Karrueche Tran is that I don't know how
to say this woman's name please educate
me but this looks very TLC era I'm kind
of into this this looks like you had a
very flamboyant sexy dad and you got
into his closet and just decided to wear
his red satin wide-leg pant tuxedo to
the I heart music radio awards for radio
music hearts Jason Derulo male ankles
mangles are big trends at this award
show I don't hate it it's raining a lot
in Los Angeles so they're all prepared
you're a cater waiter that got off is
shift it was like oh [ __ ] I could be at
the iHeartRadio Music Radio for heart of
music radio award and then you stop by
Michaels you ironed on some Rose decals
and bam you're not serving and tartar
anymore you are a star star what I just
blacked out what did I just say Joe
Jonas huh give me them ankles there are
thoughts can suck a dick in 2017 turns
out he's got a windbreaker or a blazer
maybe it's a wind blazer also are people
only allowed to wear red black white and
silver to this award show because okay
are you look like Joe Jonas that's cool
good for your throat so dude what up the
news today there do are you the one
engines or is it the other brother this
is offensive I'm sorry Maddie Ziegler to
your favorite dance moms dancer
look at you wearing what are those
French bulldogs no they're butterflies
I like the shorts and then you're
wearing the tuxedo type
shirt is it a one-piece I don't know you
look uncomfortable and you're having a
fun time q Chloe from Dance Moms but she
took a break from Dance Moms to do a
bunch of other stuff and now she is back
on Dance Moms that's a huge big old
spoiler if you guys weren't caught up
this is a very cute like ice dancer
Meets Dancing with the Stars costume fun
you look moderately uncomfortable in
your body you okay that's it for the IR
radio show Music Awards of fashion for
shows with some Radio Music Awards let
me know who you guys loves on the red
carpet and if I missed anyone that you
really really were fond of let me know
in the comments down below give this
video a thumbs up if you like these
fashion reviews and let me know what
other award shows are coming up that you
think I should be reviewing in the new
year to distant future and put this
button to subscribe to this YouTube
channel because I make videos Monday
Wednesday Friday except sometimes I
don't make them on those days it's a fun
little game that we have where you come
to see if I live up to the expectations
that I set for myself and for you and
sometimes it's it's a bummer subscribe
that's it see you next time I don't know
barely Ray Cyrus honestly I thought this
was Mike Meyers playing Wayne from
Wayne's World and he just showed up to
this red carpet I had no idea this was
Billy Ray Cyrus you're doing a really
great Mike Meyers Wayne's World Wayne's
impersonation right now